[موسيقى]
عقوبه شديده تنتظر نجوم اوروغواي جماهير
كوريا تحتفلوا حتى الصباح ابن ميسي يسير
على خطى الاخطبوط بول هذه الاخبار وغيرها
تتابعون على العربيه رياضه اهلا بكم
بعد اقصاء منتخب اوروغواي من كاس العالم
دخل لاعب في نوبه غضب قد تكلفهم عقوبه
الثقيله محاوله نجم المنتخب
وبعد الانجاز الذي حققه المنتخب الكوري
بتاهله الى ثمن النهائي احتفلت الجماهير
الكوريه حتى الساعات الاولى من الفجر
السبت ولم تمنع الاجواء البارده او حتى
الوقت المتاخر الكوريين من الاحتفال بهذا
الانجاز الذي لا يتكرره في كل مشاركه
وبعد الاخطبوط بول الذي كان يتوقع نتائج
المباريات في مونديال جنوب افريقيا يبدون
الدور اتى على ابن ميسي خلال مباراه
الارجنتين وبولندا لم يتوقع فقط
الارجنتين على استراليا بثلاثه اهداف لهدف
صورته تم تداوله على النطاق واسع في
السوشيال ميديا فهل يكون توقعوا صحيحا
وفي خبرنا الاخير تلقى اليوم عشاق كره
القدم حول العالم انباء في حاله صحيه
خارجه واكدت تقارير صحفيه برازيليه لم يعد
يستجيب للعلاج الكيميائي مشيرتا لانه يحصل
حاليا على جرعه مكثفه من المسكنات لتخفيف
الام السرطان الذي يعاني منه منذ بدايه
العام الحالي
[موسيقى]